Contrôle des maladies Sanders a confirmé
que le virus a passé à travers les
États-Unis d'Amérique pour éviter d'être infecté
du tout le public l'appelle de la nourriture pour vers d'
accord ce regard sur 50 gouvernements en
état d'alerte élevée Je ne sais pas si l'un d'entre vous
suit les nouvelles si  tu n'es pas tu
devrais être il y a quelque chose qui
rend les gens malades fous fous ce qui
s'est passé je ne sais
pas va chercher l'
infirmière  à la maison
comprenez-vous que vraiment faire la fête comme si
nous ne pouvions pas quitter la maison pendant un mois seul
nous pouvons faire ce que nous voulons
pourquoi faisons-nous à la maison yo je te parle
réponds-moi bébé tu as les
yeux chauds  la grippe ne montre aucun signe d'
arrêt aux États-Unis,
en fait, nous ne pouvons pas partir sans elle et
laissez-moi ne peut pas arrêter cela et cela envahit
votre corps - se transforme en signalez-le, vous
devez le combattre et McQueen
va me faire
éviter les légumes
[  Musique]